Well, here's a surprise: James Gunn's The
Suicide Squad might just feature a Big Bad
who is... well, pretty big and pretty bad.
Rumor-slinging website We Got This Covered
is reporting that their oh-so anonymous sources
tell them that the main villain of the upcoming
soft reboot will be none other than Vandal
Savage, an iconic DC villain with a very long
history.
The gang being assembled for The Suicide Squad
is an interesting mix of the familiar and
the new.
Margot Robbie will be reprising her role as
Harley Quinn, arguably the star of the show
the first time around; also returning are
Viola Davis as Amanda Waller, Joel Kinnaman
as team leader Rick Flag, and Jai Courtney
as Captain Boomerang.
New to the proceedings this time around are
David Dastmalchian as Polka-Dot Man, Daniela
Melchior as a gender-flipped version of the
criminal known as Ratcatcher, and Steve Agee
as the voice of King Shark.
A slew of famous names have also been cast
in undisclosed roles, although John Cena is
widely believed to be taking on the role of
Peacemaker, a vigilante so stridently committed
to the cause of peace that he'll straight-up
kill you if you aren't.
Also among the cast are Idris Elba, Storm
Reid, Nathan Fillion, Michael Rooker, Peter
Capaldi, and Taika Waititi.
Plot rumors suggest that the movie will see
Waller sending in the Suicide Squad to deal
with some kind of alien beast that has been
held captive in a secret prison built by the
Nazis during the Second World War.
This monster is now under the sway of two
villains, referred to in the synopsis only
as "the Mayor" and "the General."
These rather official-sounding names may indeed
hint at Savage, as in the pages of DC comics,
the villain has played a part in world events
throughout all of history.
Savage came into the world as an actual caveman,
but was granted a powerful intellect and immortality
by a mysterious, radioactive meteorite that
fell to Earth in his vicinity.
He's basically been playing the governments
and societies of the world like a fiddle for
roughly 50,000 years, and it's suggested that
he may have taken on the mantle of a wide
array of different historical figures.
Oh, and he's been revered as a god and exalted
as a ruler by multiple civilizations throughout
history.
So yeah, how's that for a Big Bad?
Obviously, it needs to be said that this rumor
should be taken with about six pounds of salt.
We Got This Covered is hardly the most reliable
source of inside info, and while the site
has fielded accurate rumor reports in the
past, it has also fielded more than its fair
of share of complete bunk.
It should also be pointed out that the plot
synopsis has in no way been confirmed, and
that Gunn himself has said that a good deal
of the rumors floating about concerning The
Suicide Squad are untrue.
There have also been a good number of other
baddies rumored for the film.
Other "inside sources" have asserted, for
example, that Capaldi will be portraying frequent
Teen Titans antagonist Psimon, while some
have insisted that the alien monster mentioned
in the synopsis will be none other than J'Onn
J'Onnz, also known as Martian Manhunter.
Until Gunn decides to give fans some inside
info or even a trailer all of this should
be taken as pure speculation.
The truth is, nobody outside of the production
yet knows who The Suicide Squad's main antagonist
will be.
Well, almost nobody, that is.
Speaking on his Fatman Beyond podcast last
June, filmmaker and quintessential comic book
geek Kevin Smith revealed that he is, in fact,
privy to that particular information.
Smith asked his audience if they had heard
the news about the movie's villain, and when
nobody responded in the affirmative, he admitted
he had figured everyone knew already.
"I thought that everybody knew and I was about
to say but I was like Wait…
I might have heard that.
“Feel free to break something.”
“I might have heard that privately."
Unfortunately, Smith was reluctant to spill
any details about what he'd heard — but
what he did say was pretty encouraging.
"If it is what I heard it is f------ phenomenal.
And boy it is in the right hands with James
Gunn"
Well, then: bring on August 2021.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.